tu as pris un vol low cost pourquoi
avant l'holocauste
nous sommes ici pour la succession de
votre mère décédée en son domicile de 29
août 2011 à paris france - 40
centimètres de trop tirer une petite
sardines
j'avais pas du tout envie de pleurer
non je suis pas médecin mais je sais ce
que je suis en ce moment c'est la chose
à vous dire non pour vos papilles en
doute les endeuillés cdo dur je suis
personne je le sais quel âge maintenant
à ton fils vient d'avoir fabriqué ce qui
fait c'est pas faire ses études à mur
entre départ d'elie et maman ça fait
beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup pour tout le monde en
fit et de cette remise spéciale de
l'ouest cco qui venait de perdre votre
maman ma mère habite et 13 seulement la
peau ça m'en fous tout démolir tous des
océans et sauf que heureusement bail est
très attaché j'hésite entre que de liège
pourrait refaire le plancher aussi et
égyptienne grèce ont fait rechuter très
beau touche à rien on le laisse comme il
est c'est la mémoire
bon allez on va dire la prière ce que tu
vas mal nantis l'a pas mise la facture
ainsi qu'à toi c'est dégueulasse
mais comme des cons tout seul papa maman
poule 1
jugé mace par contre vous mais je vais
pas raconter ma vie annacone tu viens de
faire une coloscopie heures tu as montré
ton trou du cul pourtant c'est très
intime et tu le connaissais pas